[Applause]
and
[Applause]
liftoff of the falcon 9 and dart
lighting up the californian sky nasa
takes its first shot at cosmic billiards
tucked inside its rocket is the dart
spacecraft on a mission to crash into an
asteroid in the hope of nudging it off
course
it's a test run but one day the strategy
might be needed to save the planet from
a catastrophic impact
i do sleep well at night i don't uh over
interpret or stress about the hazard but
it is something that's out there and if
you could prevent an earthquake or a
hurricane you want to have that
technology in place and this is a
situation where we could potentially
prevent a natural disaster and that's
why we want to have this technique in
our back pocket proven in space so it's
there if we need it
dart's target is dimorphos a space rock
160 meters across which is orbiting
around a larger asteroid called dirimos
in september next year it'll smash into
the rock at 15 000 miles an hour it
should nudge dimorphos into a slightly
shorter quicker orbit which scientists
should quickly see as it spins around
its twin
an asteroid a little larger than a
football pitch would wipe out a city and
the region around it the good news is
that nasa hasn't seen anything yet that
we need to lose sleep over certainly not
in the next 100 years the bad news is
they reckon they've only catalogued 40
of the significant near-earth objects
out there here it comes
[Music]
when there's no gravity to hold things
down even small objects can have a
disproportional impact as demonstrated
by astronauts on the international space
station
no need to resort to nuclear bombs to
divert an asteroid
as favored by hollywood disaster movies
if you're going to send a nuclear bomb
up it's probably you're probably not
going to be able to send it so far away
as we would need to because of the
energy it takes to get the nuclear bomb
up so you're going to be hitting the
rock quite close to the earth
if
the bomb does what it's supposed to do
which is break up the big rock then the
earth will be hit by a whole shower of
radioactive rocks
which is not much of an
improvement space rocks collide with the
earth every day but rarely are the
meteors as large as the one that
exploded over russia in 2013.
that wasn't even 20 meters across yet it
caused extensive damage and nasa says
it's best to be prepared for even worse
thomas more sky news